when we meet people and they say what do
you do
[Music]
I start by saying do you know who Wes
Anderson is
[Music]
welcome to movie people where we meet
passionate fans whose favorite film or
director left a big impression on their
lives I love you but you don't know what
you're talking about
[Music]
love you too today we're looking at the
world of Wes Anderson and those who live
in it like Wally and Amanda Koval the
creators behind the Beloved travel book
accidentally Wes Anderson
let's go to Brooklyn New York to hear
Wally and Amanda's story and how Wes
inspired them to create an accidental
community
[Music]
foreign
begin
I mean my first film was watching
Rushmore with my dad
was this like a Saturday morning or
something and it was on TV and I didn't
know what this was but it was quirky and
it was weird and my dad's cracking up at
it but also this kind of like dark
undertone little twisted little weird
and when something of Wes came out
that's like the only time we actually go
to the movies I think the first one I
saw was in this apartment in this
apartment yeah when we first started
dating I mean we've been together 15
years
so how do you accidentally make a book
well Amanda and I started a travel
bucket list
that's why I started the Instagram
account
find an interesting place post once a
day
what it is when it was and where it was
built
it started to expand
[Music]
we reached out to the community
someone said hey we're thinking about
making a book we love your photo and we
love the story that it has
would you be open to use your photo in
this
months of whittling down
20 000 photos to 200.
Dexter had a good part in that we would
put treats on the ones that we wanted
we are not authors we're not writers
we're not photographers it was just a
culmination of all the people who had
never done any of this stuff before all
very accidentally
and yet
we went out in the world and made this
thing but he has finals say
and I don't know him I had never met him
Amanda how many times did we write the
letter like 30 times
and we reached out to West and we're
like hey could we make a book
[Music]
he penned the forward
just had Smiles on her faces for like
weeks and a lot of Tears
[Music]
look at that thing that's
real
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
tell us about your AWA community of
Adventures oh my God yeah we always say
community with a Capital C in AWA World
Community is a proper noun
and it's nice and it's positive and
friendly yeah it's wild the people that
we met
C is a great example of like a lifelong
friend she takes these incredible pool
photos and was one of our very early
members
Jeffrey zum who has now said like you've
helped me become a photographer and put
that first and foremost so excited to
tell Kathy that this was Wes's favorite
photo and she was like I literally
snapped that in the rain on like an
iPhone 4 and she's not a photographer
she's a yoga instructor but I was like
well you've made an impact
yes you touch on architecture yes you
touch on history but then touching on
people
I think is what's the most interesting
part
[Music]
foreign
what are your favorite Community stories
to ask us to pick our favorite from the
book is like asking to pick your
favorite child
I love this story Buckingham Palace a
member of the community said my
grandmother actually worked at
Buckingham Palace and was paid in
dresses bet you never knew that the
Washington state fairies it's one of the
oldest and largest Ferry systems in the
United States you know this place in
Dresden Germany was once a tobacco
facility and now it's just an office
building these are just hotels that
happen to be amazing these are
lighthouses around the world
[Music]
that is an Old Barney or Barnegat Light
in Long Beach Island
[Music]
I grew up going to Long Beach Island as
a kid with my dad
he battled pancreatic cancer for about a
year and then passed away
I'm I'll say I'm not a writer I've never
been a writer but I would send it to him
a draft and get his you know feelings on
it and that that was that was not there
through the end of this and so I wanted
that photo there
that was actually a new member of the
community we reached out to him and I
told him the importance of it and he was
incredibly gracious and Incredibly kind
and yeah
[Music]
we like inadvertently curated this group
of amazing humans
their ability to kind of like take these
really tiny moments and share the really
amazing stories that they have to tell
[Music]
there's there's something crazy about
that
if you enjoyed this little look into the
world of Wes Anderson then I'm willing
to bet you're going to enjoy Wally and
Amanda's thoughts on his newest film
asteroid City how long can they keep us
in Asteroid City legally the world will
never be the same that's mainly doing
jumping jacks that's an aliener top pack
this is the perfect example of
everything that he's put together up
until now
there's so many layers to it and it's
it's fast paced and then there are
certain points that you're kind of
connecting the dots back and forth to
that I feel like it's one of the movies
you have to see at least three times
do you think it's a masterpiece is
anything that he does not a master yes
what kind of question is that
so there you have it it has the
accidentally West Anderson 's stamp of
approval go see asteroid City now
playing in select cities everywhere on
June 23rd
from director Wes Anderson I don't like
the way that guy looked at us the alien
like we're doomed maybe we are what a
strange experience this is asteroid City
Invaders everywhere June 23rd
[Music]
no